[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace
philippe noiret des clayes-sous-bois
nous vous proposons une semaine de
cinéma à la française puisque nous
aurons quatre films en tous genres
français avec deux comédies le lion je
suis le dr tardy commencé par me dire
comment vous appelez et au milan nom de
code le lion les homes il en existe pas
si la couverture
c'était un bon guide ou quoi et l'esprit
de famille unie plus la coupe est trop
court je sais que je te retourne un
thriller les traducteurs et un film
d'animation samsam en sortie nationale à
partir trois ans pour les enfants le
thriller réalisé par régis roinsard avec
lambert wilson
les traducteurs nous raconte l'histoire
de neuf traducteur enfermé dans une
luxueuse demeure afin de traduire le
dernier tome d'un très célèbre roman
internationale mais lorsque les dix
premières pages du roman sont publiées
sur internet est un pirate menace de
dévoiler la suite si on ne lui reverse
pas une rançon colossal une question
devient obsédante qui est le coupable
un scénario palpitant qui vous fera
frémir d'inquiétude
ce thriller les traducteurs est fait
pour vous à retrouver nous donc à
l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]